لم تكن هذه الصور مشهدا عاديا في تاريخ
الصراع تبث كتائب القسام مشاهد لتصدي
دفاعتها الجويه كما تقول للمقاتلات
الاسرائيليه في سماء قطاع غزه الطائرات
الاسرائيليه الشنت غارات على مواقع
للمقاومه في القطاع وسلطات الاحتلال تقول
انها استهدفت معسكر لقوه الدفاع الجويه
لحركه حماس القصف الاسرائيلي جاء ردا على
صواريخ انطلقت من القطاع ردا على الهجوم
الاخير على جنين شماليه الضفه الغربيه
الفصائل الفلسطينيه هددت الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي برد على سقوط الشهداء خلال
اقتحام مخيم جنين صحيح الان هي من الفصائل
لم يتبنى اطلاق الصواريخ من انقطاع غزه
الا ان اسرائيل تحمل حماس دائما المسؤوليه
عنها فلا يمكن ان تطلق صواريخ من القطاع
دون قرار سياسيين وعسكريا في فلسطينيه
تقول اسرائيل في الضفه الغربيه الاحتلال
وتدفع بكتيبته من لواء المظليين الى مناطق
التوتر
اكادات تتدحرج كره التوتر في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه تشتبك الساحات من اقصى شمال
الضفه الغربيه الى اقصى جنوب قطاع غزه
مرورا بالقدس ذلك امر لم يكن مالوفا قبل
معركه سيف القدس سيف عام 2021
بعد تلك الايام من القتال انعطف الصراع
الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي وعسكريا نحو مزيد من
التوتر لا تقبل اسرائيل برد فلسطيني من
غزه على ما يحدث في جنين ولا يقبل
الفلسطينيون ان لا يرد من غزه على ما يحدث
في جنين سياسيا يحط وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه رحاله في المنطقه خلال 48 ساعه
تقول وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان انتم
سيبحث عن سبل لتخفيض التوتر في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه سيزور القاهره ايضا بحثا عن
تلك الحلول يبدو ان الولايات المتحده لا
تريد انفلات الامور في المنطقه حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا تحظى بالاولويه والاهميه
القصوى لدى واشنطن الان تقول السلطه
الفلسطينيه ان الحل يكون في تراجع
الاحتلال عن اقتحامته اليوميه تلك
اقتحامات يسقط فيها فلسطينيون بين شهداء
وجرحى واسرى وتدمر منازلهم تقول الحكومه
الاسرائيليه انها لن تتوقف عن ملاحقتهم من
يحملون السلاح في الحكومه
وفي تطرفها وتؤكد ان اقتحامات المسجد
الاقصى لن تتوقف هذه الدائره مغلقه لا
تفتح على مفاوضات جديه تقدم للفلسطينيين
بعض ما يريدون من حقوق ولا تقدم الدائره
كذلك امنا لاسرائيل يمكنها من البقاء دون
مزيد من الدماء